one one two three four one two three
four two three
my name is David brand and I'm co host
of a show entitled film courage Karen
and I are here in tujunga California
hello my name is Karen warden this is
the place of the station fire infamous
station fire as you can see where we're
amongst the charred territory and we
thought this was an appropriate place
for this video because it reflects how
the distribution model has burned down
you know the world of distributing your
films is changing and it's time for
growth is time for for a new model to
emerge but the reason i'm doing this
video today is to put a call out to all
the film lovers out there or to nominate
the film ink for the john cassavetes
award i think it's just a brilliant film
and i think it deserves that nomination
here I have the special package that
just came in the mail and I haven't even
opened it yet because I wanted you know
Karen I want to do this video and let me
go ahead and get this going why they
really they really pack this thing tight
so but this is a very some time looking
forward to there is my very own copy
film entitled ink how about that and the
sad thing is is very likely it won't
even be nominated for the award so we're
going to do what we can here to see if
we can push and make people aware here's
our challenge to you if you can name
four films I want to know which four
films that you think deserve the
Cassavetes award / Inc we challenge you
to list those in the text section of
this YouTube video
you